so you mentioned earlier that if it went
people to reach out to you for advice
say there's really no standard way
what's the best and worst piece of
advice you've ever seen um that's really
tough that's hard to think you know it's
funny cuz i don't actually thinking
about i don't i haven't asked for a lot
of advice I've in terms of reaching out
to strangers i think the very first one
actually was actually before I remember
my first short film was one of the times
I significantly remember remember asking
for advice and was a friend of mine from
junior high that I hadn't seen since 8th
grade and I saw that he'd made a film
and that was kind of what I wanted to do
so I emailed him hey I saw your film
that was really cool like your
writer-director like had to do it you
know and that and he just responded the
main one was just you or you you know
you're unique so write your story it's
like you know try to tell your stories
don't try to tell what you think other
people want to hear
that stuck with me and it's he hasn't
made a film since then actually which is
funny because I thought he's more of an
actor and he's I think he continues to
act but that was his only film that he
made so it was interesting to see my
career kind of take one direction while
he kind of gave me advice and then
didn't continue direct and I thought
that was interesting the worst piece of
advice I again I don't think I've had
that because I think everyone's advice
is just our advice again it's nothing
where it's the holy grail of right
answers it's not necessarily wrong
either it's just you just collect you
know you filter what works for you so I
can't recall getting bad advice
you